she's an author life coach and
motivational speaker she has written
seven best-selling books she's a
millionaire entrepreneur who has helped
millions of people discover their
infinite potential she's Lisa Nichols
and here's my take on her top 50 rules
for success
enjoy alright let's kick it off with
rule number one you are your rescue I
struggled off this school the last time
I took English class I got to fail and
my English teacher said I was the
weakest rider she ever met in her entire
life
the last time I took a speech class same
here I got a d-minus in speech and my
speech too should say at least a quote
unquote I recommend you never speak in
public that you get a desk job so that
was the beginning of my life that was
the that was my 19 year old experience
and then I go on and I'm trying to
figure it out trying to figure it out
I was obedient I went and got a job in
accounting I was in the collection
department for seven years y'all don't
know I'm dangerous to accounting I'm not
just dangerous and I'm in collections
and you know you should never put a
broke person in collection never because
everybody's reasons sound good to me not
only did I say girl
don't you worry about payin I'm gonna
take your name off the list because I
was like ooh I got fired from five
different jobs and then I got pregnant
with my son unexpectedly and then at
eight months my son's father went to
prison I have to get on government
assistance to have my baby I was on WIC
women infants children to feed my child
and when my son was eight months old I
went to the ATM to get $20 out the bank
cuz I didn't have any pampers for him
and in order to get $20 out she got that
$20 in I had $11 in 42 cents and I still
can't tell the store without getting
emotional cuz it's my story for two days
I had to wrap my son in a towel but
something happened Steve in those two
days I was at rock bottom I was broke
and I was broken Inglewood California my
son laying on his back at eight months I
have a towel over him and I have my hand
on his stomachs and don't you worry
jeylani mommy will never be
this broke again and I made a decision I
was bankrupt and every stinking thinking
I had I was bankrupt and trying to
protect my pride I was bankrupt and
trying to be all that in a bag of chips
and a bowl of grits falsified I was
bankrupt and trying to not ask anyone
for help I was bankrupt in everything
that was holding me and keeping me where
I was I've always talked a good game but
I wasn't doing anything with my gift and
all that thing about potential I was
tired of having potential I wanted to
have my now and I looked at that baby at
eight months and I said I want to
transform your life because you didn't
ask to come into this chaos well as an
african-american male child in South
Central Los Angeles with a single mother
whose fathers in prison he had a 66%
chance of going to prison himself not on
my watch not on my watch so if I have to
be willing to drastically transform
myself so that I can become the woman
but I know I can be right and that's
what I began to do I was radical what
did you do Lisa what what did you do to
change your life
first I realize I couldn't grow with
people who were struggling like me that
hole I don't want to leave nobody behind
you know I don't want to stay with y'all
right be the queen of this block yeah
and I became okay what the fact that it
doesn't make me any less committed to my
community committed to my culture
committed to my family the best thing I
can do for you is not stay here with you
that's right when I've got that I went
to places I'd never seen before I went
to conferences where people talk about
money talking about prosperity yeah
talking about it was like no habla
espanol what's your tongue though ro
eyes and PPM's and term agreements and
capital fundraising and bottom lines and
what is it was i'ma stay until I learn
what you're talkin about
I went to the same conference 42 times
and there I raised five hundred and
thirty-two thousand dollars in capital
from my company's start my dream and my
dream was to transform teen lives I want
to teach teens how to format
themselves and how to make integrity
based decisions and I got it funded and
I started working and that was the
beginning of me rescuing myself I
realized that I am my rescue no one else
is my rescue rule number two believe in
the unseen so I was hungry like I was
hungry people often want to call me the
exception like oh my god you're the
exception no I'm not the exception I'm
an average ordinary woman who chose
every day to make one more extraordinary
decision I'm an average ordinary mom who
said I want to drastically transform my
son's future that he deserves to have
every option that every other child
would have irregardless of what he was
born into I just was crazy enough to
believe that that it doesn't matter the
color of my skin doesn't matter my
religious background doesn't matter my
origin it doesn't matter my mom's bank
account my dad's been counting I was
born none of that means my future that's
just the circumstance that I came from
that's not what defines my future I just
believe that not a lot validated it but
faith is believing in the unseen anyway
so I have enough faith to go I know like
I know like I know like I know I don't
necessarily have to see it yet rule
number three use affirmations Christy
talked about affirmations abundant
thinkers understand the power of I am
anything after the word I am is true to
your unconscious mind Michael anything
anything after I am anything anything
after I am even if you just you know
it's not true your conscious mind will
believe it anything after I am so the
use of affirmations is very intentional
and very consistent I was diagnosed as
clinically depressed and 2001 1998 I'm
sorry I was diagnosed as clinically
depressed me it didn't make sense I had
been in a relationship I was engaged to
get married and my fiancee who I did not
know at the time was bipolar and he'd
stopped taking his medicines and under
the belief system that love can cure
anything
and so I ended up being picked up and
thrown three feet across the room and I
end up being choked until I passed out
and once I got out of that relationship
I just was different it was different so
my mom insisted that I go to the doctor
I went to the doctor and I sat on the
table and she checked me and talked to
me and came back in with a prescription
and she said ELISA you're clinically
depressed and I felt like I heard
Charlie Brown's parents talking like
womp womp womp womp womp clinically
depressed at least don't that make sense
in that same sentence and she'd get
handed me a prescription and I read the
description and had my name on it and it
said Prozac I said that don't make sense
Lisa Nichols wrote that don't make sense
and I said do you mean I'm sad she said
very very sad I said can I try something
and I'm not I'm not recommending you
guys if you're on medication you stop
taking meds please don't do that I asked
my doctor she agreed I said do you mind
if I try something before I take this
she goes yes but I need to see you back
in 30 days if you're in the same
condition I need us to try it this
medicine I said okay I could do that so
I went home and every day I got in the
mirror and I drilled I am every day
because I realized I have forgotten who
I was
I just forgot I just and it was okay to
forget I just forgot so every day every
day for 25 minutes I just went over the
IMS every day I am I am I am and that I
pay off that with I forgive you for
then I parallel that when I commit to
you Lisa every single day I went back in
30 days and I'm talking to her and I'm
on fire she's just looking at me I'm
just talking talking twisted her head
again and I'm just talking talking she
says wait I gotta stop yeah so what she
goes what are you taking and can I have
some I was like I'm taking some of me
and so the power of I am the power of I
ant can pull you through the darkest
moment the power of I am rule number
four create holistic success success is
personally defined by everyone
and as you're creating success create
holistic success my bit my biggest
successes are the things that people
don't even see it's the fact that my 14
year old son caused me his best friend
to his friends that's bigger that's
bigger than any book deal that you can
give me that's bigger than sitting
across from Larry King or beside Oprah
that my 14 year old son caused me his
best friend creating holistic success is
really important also if you want to
learn how to have more confidence second
by 2:54 series they're free the links
aren't in the scription below we
validate who we are by what we're doing
for other people I say if your knees
aren't knocking and your teeth are
chattering just a little at least then
you're not playing big enough it lands a
little easier I remember there was a
time in my life when all I wanted was
for people to accept me rule number five
do something different let me tell you
in order to have something different you
are going to have to do something
different in order to have something
more you have to do something you
haven't done yet I have to say the
things I didn't want to say do the
things I didn't feel like doing to have
the life I know I wanted period period
and all I did was give instructions for
here do this bite size do this bite size
do this bite size bite-size digestible
palatable pieces of what you can do that
sound good you guys and when you look up
and you don't have to have a magnificent
change over 12 months have a small
change over 30 days and then a small
change over 30 days your breakthrough
comes will come in needlepoint moves and
you'll look up look up in five years and
not recognize your life rule number six
stop asking for permission what's been
your biggest accomplishment you think
bouncing back number one is refusing to
listen to the negative chatter my own
head refusing to listen to other
people's perception of me creating
something from absolutely nothing so I
got a you know there's the books there's
the TV there's all that stuff but my
biggest accomplishment is being willing
to give myself a thousand second chances
and every time I got to 999 I press
reset yeah I didn't ask permission I
gave notice and at some point I have to
stop
asking cannot be great can I be
brilliant can I be okay and still be
accepted I just stopped asking
permission and just gave notice
unapologetically not in a braggadocious
way not in a way that shrunk anyone else
in a way that said I only got one life
and i'ma ride this one to the wheels
fall off and then all the other stuff
came well as a result of a decision I
made right but it was a decision it was
a decision but it was and it didn't come
from you know a motivational experience
it didn't come from an inspiring teacher
it came from hitting rock bottom rule
number seven disrupt your soil there's
so much value in what you unlearn
sometimes the best thing you can do is
unlearn some things we're all always
going after learning something new
because we're information junkies
because we have all these forms of
information coming at us on the internet
coming at us in books coming at us on
the radio coming at us in television
that we want to learn learn learn but
sometimes your biggest breakthrough is
in what you unlearn and then you relearn
sometimes you have to disrupt your soil
pull your soil up take that dry dirt
that's been planted for years I know
I've just been knowing this for years
it's what my mother taught me that's
what we've always done you have to
disrupt that soil in order to plant a
new seed to grow a new fruit yeah yeah
you guys got that and so I came very
comfortably to disrupt your soil like
that's what I came for to disrupt your
soil not to necessarily keep you
comfortable what you know stay
comfortable that I want to disrupt you
with some things that are new awareness
to go oh wait hold on or new awareness
about what you've been doing based on
what you've known forever that doesn't
fit your future anymore because I can
guarantee you every single one of us who
want something different than what we're
getting we're doing something
unconsciously from all patterns that
doesn't even serve our future that's
when the tongue in your mouth and the
tongue in your shoe are going in two
totally different directions and your
job is to align them up so that you can
move forward in a powerful way
rule number eight unpack your story
every single thing you touch is impacted
by your story as an attorney as a
teacher as an architect there's not one
a business that you can be in that a
story and a great story won't elevate
your outcome every single line of
business every single line of service
that you're connected to will be
impacted and ideally elevate it by the
level in which you're willing to tell
and share your story so let me give you
some guidelines some parameters what I
like to call the bumper rails as if
you're going bowling you know when I go
bowling I ask them to put the little
bumper rails down so I can stick my ball
can get down the lane so let me set up
some bumper rails for you so that you
understand what makes a great story so
one is the willingness to take risk
most people vision when they're telling
a story they don't want to take a risk
so the story has it has its limits on
how high it will go or how deep it'll go
and when you have that then you're
really not at that part that's gonna
touch my soul so being willing to take a
risk being clear and concise with your
story's a great story is a ShowMe story
not a tell me story now this is the
distinction that's the game-changer for
most most people were telling a story
they say so let me just share with you a
little bit of my story and I'll tell you
and then I'll show you so as I was
building my life there was a time in my
life that was very difficult it was very
challenge true story very difficult very
challenging very uncomfortable I didn't
have a lot of money I didn't have a lot
of hope and things just look dismal at
some point I had to turn my life around
at some point I made the decision that
life had to get better I'm telling you
that lets decent you learn about me then
if I were to show you that story I would
say six days a week I had to eat beanies
and weenies I had to find money in the
crevices and the corners of my couch so
that I can get my son milk there were
times when my heart would beat fast just
at what am I gonna have tomorrow at some
point I got sick and tired of my own
story is this gonna be my future
can't handle it notice the difference in
that seconds - wrong I completely see
that I just painted a picture same story
now the second one will you show a story
it's gonna require more of you it's
gonna require you to find the colors
what were you thinking what were you
experiencing what was going on in your
head instead of telling me you look for
money turn and point now this is
anywhere this is anywhere you are doing
anything I promise you become a great
storyteller and you will have to Veit
your audience no matter what you're
doing
I've captivated investors I've
captivated students I've captivated
educators because I was willing to show
the story
I call it unpacking the story vision
being willing to tell me what were you
thinking what were you feeling
what were you saying think about a story
as an oral movie and so in an oral movie
think when you're looking at a movie the
first thing they do is they identify
what state of time it is is a futuristic
is it in the now was it back in the day
you notice that based on what people are
wearing how they're talking so paint
that picture for me take me to that
environment set the backdrop up for me
show me what you're going through
instead of saying I was angry you can
tell me you're angry but when you say
the hair on the back of my neck was
standing up I felt the fumes exiting my
nose I thought that my chest was going
to pop and I was gonna say something
that I'd regret forever who you just
showed me you were angry take that extra
time to unpack it
why will most people not do that because
it requires a level of vulnerability
that we're not willing to share rule
number nine find true abundance myth
number two is that abundance is
singularly focused on possessions and
money right that's what it's all about
what you drive what you live in how much
money you make when in fact this
couldn't be further from the truth
wealth is possessions and money
abundance is a 360 experience abundance
is a 360 experience true abundance true
abundance is your health because if you
don't have great health life does not
feel good abundance is relationship and
at the end of your life literally you
will measure the quality of your life by
the quality of the relationships you had
all the other stuff will fall away that
promotion you thinking about you're
wondering about that race it will fall
away in an area of importance when you
get to the end of your life you will
begin to look at the quality of your
relationships how are your children
related to you how your siblings
relationship do you have love in your
life you literally will start looking at
relationships at a higher level as you
get older so when you mind them now you
take care of them and I know that for a
fact I have a friend who's who's worth
14 billion dollars billion would it be
he was just partying at my house all
night long wouldn't leave 4 in the
morning go home and he flew in from
Canada to go to my New Year's party
because he loves my family connection
and he doesn't have one he is
financially wealthy
he's relationship broke so that makes
sense
abundance is a 360 experience it's about
relationships it's about health it's
about your spiritual groundedness that
doesn't mean you have a religious origin
it's about can you release can you
forgive can you let go can you be still
do you meditate do you have time with
yourself that has a lot to do with the
quality of your life that ability
rule number 10 dream big
[Music]
and I have a message for you a very
important message we live in a world
where you know limiting beliefs and
limited thinking is accepted and in some
environments it's actually encouraged
not to put anyone down or any
institution down but look at our
educational system it's bound by who you
can be who you can be we're taught that
you know as a academic excellent student
you were expected to achieve more
pressures but yet even inside that more
that higher achievement they're still a
limiting belief there you know look at
my life today and it's barely
recognizable I'm grateful to say I have
six bestsellers I set with Oprah with
Larry King on CNN good to LA I've
traveled all over the world to work in
Taipei in Africa and Kazakhstan but that
wasn't where I started I started
struggling for 12 years in the
educational system not thinking I was
good enough the word fail are not passed
was threaded through every year in
school in some area or another and so I
graduated I got out I mean I graduated
but what did I graduate to I graduated
more of who took more of who I think I
might be able to be or who I couldn't be
but not my possibility I look up and for
the first 10 15 years of my adulthood I
struggled I struggled because I didn't
dream big enough at that time I didn't
know I felt like my dreams were covered
and smothered with the cultural
limitations were defined by who our
parents were what our culture can do
what our community can do so you look at
all the areas of our lives financially
mentally emotionally family
geographically and all of those things
kind of put us in a box and some of our
boxes are this big so we think they're
amazing some of them are this big and we
know that choking the life out of us the
reality is we're trained to be realistic
to be logical to stay practical
and there's nothing realistic and
logical about Steve Jobs in his journey
there's nothing realistic 'el and
logical about dr. Martin Luther King and
his willingness to be radical for a
change that none of us saw coming
there's nothing realistic about Nelson
Mandela leaving prison after 27 years
and leading the largest forgiveness
movement ever
there's nothing realistic and logical
come on even my journey born and raised
in South Central Los Angeles having
three bites a week just to get home from
school you know being told that I was
the weakest writer my teacher had ever
met and that I should never speak in
public by my speech teacher so looking
at my life today and and going on and
having a child before I got married and
getting on government's assistance just
to feed my baby not having money to buy
him pampers and wrapping my son in a
towel for three days until I can afford
to get money to buy a pampers I look at
my life and I wasn't supposed to be Who
I am today
something turned but it didn't come from
outside it didn't come from my culture
or my my community it came from within
who I was committed to transforming my
life into just didn't fit it didn't fit
realistic it didn't fit practical and it
didn't fit logical I didn't know how I
was going to get there there were no
examples of how I would get there there
was no instructions there was no GPS and
there wasn't even anyone around me that
had an idea of how to help me all there
was was my intuition my internal GPS my
internal God placement system and the
wheel and the desire and the big dream
inside my belly and I was willing to
keep at it until I'd burst something
greater than myself in order to live the
life you love and love the life you live
you have to be willing to step on the
other side of normal on
on the other side of where people give
you permission to step you have to be
willing to step on the other side of
realistic you have to be willing to
dream big and give yourself a radical
chance for a radical future and a
breathtaking possibility it starts with
you I promise
rule number eleven disrupt your standard
run into so many people all around the
world who are living this duality one I
want more but two I don't want to
disrupt what I have and the challenge is
in order for you to have a breakthrough
to the next level your your your
standard your average and your ordinary
has to be disrupted you will say oh Lisa
how do I do this and I go do this this
this and this I give you the steps and
the next thing they say is mmm that's so
hard I'm sorry did you think your breath
taking life will come on a
merry-go-round did you think you're
gonna do the swings and get there you're
gonna sweat so get up ready to sweat get
up
ready to forgive the perceiving Li
unforgivable get up ready to take the
higher Road even when the smallness in
you wants to get engaged avoid the fight
because the fight keeps you in the
little you when you're committed to
being the bigger version of yourself
yeah you gonna have to say some things
you never said and do some things you've
never done so you can meet the man the
woman you've always known yourself to be
rule number 12 create micro wins this
whole piece of my book abundance now I
wrote it a while ago and it's amazing in
terms of just talking about and breaking
down what's the difference between a
macro win and a micro win and a micro
win is that smaller goal that's you
could see it's attainable you get that
instant result and most people are
chasing the macro win all the time and
they're not looking at all the micro
wins that they can feel really
to get them to that macro result if you
create 5 7 8 10 micro wins
guess what now you're in a rhythm now
you're building some consistency now you
like the way it feels and then before
you know you look up and go whoa there's
that macro win that huge goal that I
thought was a hundred miles away it
wasn't a hundred miles away it was seven
eight eleven micro wins away rule number
13 master time management so when you
look at prioritizing it really lives in
and I must say this word and you're
probably not going to want to hear it
but when I tell you it's a game-changer
when you master and just for now begin
to operate inside of time management
I used to resist time management because
I'm a free spirit slash people will call
me a rebel back in the day meaning I
didn't want to be controlled I want it
I'm a butterfly I wanted to I wanted to
soar I wanted to be free or the reality
is that when you manage your time more
effectively you've actually create more
freedom
that was a huge off to me somebody's
gonna be lil right now like break
through out loud because when you time
manage meaning I'm gonna use better
blocks of my time let me give you some
examples for that let me use better
blocks in my time meaning I'm only gonna
go on my email three times a day I go on
my email about 9:30 between 9:20 and
9:40 I go on my email I stay in my email
for 30 minutes I'll go back in my email
about three o'clock in the afternoon I
stay in my email again for about thirty
minutes I go back a name one more time
at 6:00 p.m. I stay in for about thirty
minutes that's it I don't go in nineteen
times I don't go on twenty times because
three times a day gives me adequate time
to see
what's in there see what's new and act
appropriately otherwise it's throwing me
off I'm blocked my day about ninety
minutes each time blocked to do a task
even if a task only takes me 30 minutes
I timed like 90 minutes because I get
distracted but when you time block your
day and then you schedule each day not
every day looks the same I have a time
block for everything I need to do for
seven days out of the week can you
believe that in that time I got more
things done you have to become
comfortable with your know my
grandmother says baby
she starts every sentence with baby baby
if you want your yes to have more value
you need to learn how to exercise your
note see your yes might not have this
value anymore
why because you give it away too much
you give it to too many people you give
it away too often
you're always over committing and then
you feel drained and frustrated and you
don't have gratitude in your heart
because you're over committed well that
all started with a yes that should have
been enough or should have been a I'd
love to but not now and so number two
number one is more effective time
management that has your agenda in it it
has your priority priorities in it right
now your agenda is covered with everyone
else's task I often I heard once if you
don't have that your agenda then you're
gonna work for somebody else's agenda
and so number one is your time measure
with your agenda and number two is
operating utilizing and being
comfortable and I know and not an
attitude know not to like us
thank know like now like that mmm-hmm
just a no not now no I I would love to
put my plate is full I'm free and 90
days just don't make no no energy just
not now don't be surprised when everyone
comes to you you're great you're a may
you're brilliant look at you you're on
this channel so you know you're smart
you want a better life you want an
abundant life of course you're here
of course we won't want you and your
priorities matters rule number fourteen
leap afraid so we talked about making
your dash dance 0.1 you got to be
willing to do it
afraid see you might be waiting for the
fear to stop well Lisa I heard this so
many times Lisa I'm afraid what do I do
do it anyway Lisa I'm afraid I don't
quite know if I should move move anyway
I don't know if I should leap leap
afraid and then gather your courage on
the way down and if you don't get it
before you hit you was gonna hit anyway
I'd rather die leaping then on the edge
figuring out how to get the courage to
leap yes yes yes yes so many times we're
waiting we're waiting I'm waiting I'm
waiting to get something rise I see your
hands going up you guys know if it's
your truth you can raise your hand just
like we did on day zero you're just kind
of waiting you're waiting to get
everything in order you're waiting
you're waiting so that everything is is
Inuits together you're waiting to not be
afraid you're waiting to have the
courage you're waiting to have all the
money you're waiting to lose weight see
see if I waited to release my unwanted
pounds before I got in front of you Lisa
Nichols would be the secret yes yes I
thought how about I just leap with my
imperfection and then find my form of
perfecting my imperfection while I'm
sorry how about I do that
how about I how about you not wait to
get it right you look at you figure out
how does it look doing it wrong how does
that look because you're 80% of right is
somebody else's hundred and fifty nine
percent of what they needed yes yes and
what you want to do it right and you
want to wait too you're not afraid and
you want to wait you ever all together
Oh
you made it about you again see Nelson
Mandela did it he just did it not
knowing if you were right Mahatma Gandhi
just did it not knowing if it were right
mother Teresa just did it not looking
for affirmation or confirmation is this
right Martin Luther King did it not even
knowing if it would happen before his
life ended what are you waiting on are
you willing to do it afraid are you
willing to do it knowing that you got so
much work to do to get it better to get
it more perfect but are you willing to
do it inside your imperfection do you
realize that in your imperfection you're
perfect for the job
rule number 15 visualize visualization
is a gift to your heart and your soul
it's a gift because if the the idea is
the seed visualization is the is the
it's the fertilizer it's the fertilizer
because when your thoughts are connected
with an emotion see you would visualize
yourself winning and you would feel all
the emotion that came with that and all
you're doing now is you're not chasing a
foreign emotion you know the feeling and
now you're just doing what's necessary
to get back to that feeling in real time
and so what what a good friend of mine
vision who the CEO of my value you know
I would I did a visualization with him
we were in Bali and he said to me
afterwards I never get emotional yeah
well he was like I cried I got emotional
because I figured it out
it's visualization a good visualization
brings an emotion he was like that's how
you do it and so I love doing
visualizations because and and it's
really important in the visualization
you can't see it over there you have to
see it right here
you got to feel it right here like I am
it's all I am I am I am in my dream home
I am in my dream relationship and then
unpack what that looks like but most
importantly unpack what it feels like
and when you have that that emotion in
this moment all of a sudden you stir up
something that I don't think will ever
go back to sleep it'll go okay let's go
get that and
what it really does is it sets up a
state of cognitive dissonance and
cognitive dissonance is when you see
something in your mind and you see
yourself in a way that your behaviors
are not currently leading to us so your
mind becomes disrupted and it goes okay
can we get there right out there right
now right now and that's not comfortable
your mind wants to literally be
congruent what it thinks is what you're
doing what it thinks is what you're
doing and so when you set up a constant
and abundant thinkers like you and I we
do it unconsciously we are constantly
keeping our self in a state of cognitive
dissonance meaning okay what else and
I'm seeing Lisa over there and I'm gonna
okay let me go Wow while being grateful
for my now yeah it's not in that I'm
gonna be holding complete when I get
over there I'm holding complete now I
just know I'm supposed to be over there
so let me do what's necessary to get
over there and let me let me evict any
behaviors or characteristics that are
stopping me and let me adopt any new
ones that I need rule number sixteen
define prosperity for yourself so when
you ask the question when you look at
the question how do I create a life of
prosperity when I haven't known it when
my family hasn't done it when it's not
what we're it's not what I was born into
you know there many people was born who
were born into prosperity I wasn't one
and you may or may not be one but how
you transform a life or create lack of
prosperity is number one you identify
what does prosperity look like to you
define prosperity by your own terms and
don't make it a global Universal answer
you want to define prosperity in each
area of your life I know that sounds
like
really detailed but you cannot hit a
moving target you won't ever hit a movie
talks with the more detail you get the
more the target slows down rule number
17 trust your intuition you know when
you want to learn how to trust your
intuition more you know I say and this
is me and my walk and my my belief
system that your intuition is your
internal GPS system your internal God
placement system
it's that whisper and sometimes it's
that screamed that tells you to leap or
to be still your intuition is a
combination of spirit emotion and logic
and it's guiding you and so often we
don't hear our intuition why don't we
hear it because we're having too much
chatter in our head like the chatter in
our head doubt worry judgment oh my god
judgment or fear fear of other people's
perception of you so your intuition is
saying I love to dance I want to dance I
want to sing your intuition is saying we
can have a great time your intuition
said I want love your intuition is
saying gosh let's go take that chance on
that writing that book or let's take
that chance on starting that business
then your chatter comes in know what if
I fail so let me explain this to you
your mind your brain is designed to keep
you safe it's designed and it only has
the ability to go back in time in the
mental file cabinet and look at the last
time you tried something like this and
it may not have been good or may have
ended in some dangerous situations where
people could judge you and your brain is
designed to protect you that's it your
brains desire to protect you is logical
your intuition is that spark of passion
it's that spark of desire it's that
spark of love it's that spark of pull me
forward it's that little bit of radical
it's that a lot of bit of I want to
leave my fingerprint on this planet your
brain isn't designed to have those same
IDs now now your intuition can kick the
brain in and the brake and start
thinking of ways to but the intuition is
where it's gonna start it's in your gut
it see this is why when you feel
something you kind of go here you don't
go oh I feel so special you don't say I
feel special here you say I feel it here
I feel it here and so your job is not to
turn down the doubt your job is to turn
up the passion it's to turn up the faith
is to turn up the possibility now still
make well-thought-out plan I always say
the best plan is the plan made I don't
care if you have to upgrade it you have
to modify it but if you if you if you if
you fail to plan then you plan to fail
so every dream every passion every
desire follow it with a plan because
after your brain gets excited your brain
goes yeah we got a plan now now you can
believe yourself see you set big goals
and dreams and you have desires and then
you don't achieve it but you don't
achieve it because you didn't set the
plan in place you didn't do the details
and then you stopped believing you could
do it then you do the biggest tragedy
you stop dreaming you stop hoping you
stop stretching yourself you stop
listening to your GPS your god placement
system that says you've been put here on
a divine of thing
and your assignment may change over
years guess what your assignment you had
15 years ago may be very different from
the assignment on your life today your
job is to turn down the volume in your
head the volume of judgment the volume
of fear the volume of worry the volume
of perfection turned down the volume in
your head and turn up the volume in your
intuition then your solar plex
in that God placement system in that
heart space turn up the volume that
place that just says what do I want what
ask yourself this tonight today tomorrow
what feels good and then be still and be
quiet
rule number 18 like yourself first to me
this is the road to true freedom I have
nothing to prove mmm I have nothing to
protect add nothing to hide and I have
nothing to defend mmm that your
perception of me after I tell my truth
is actually none of my business
my perception of me that I go to bed as
whole and complete as I woke up before I
check how many likes I have on Facebook
that I like me first
mmm and every other like is bonus very
young market that was a long road to get
to low road for long road
rule number 19 play big I get asked the
question a lot how do I jump start again
when I've been complacent you know I
found that I had to ask myself this
question as well for so many years I was
working hard to feed Jelani I was
working hard to give him an equal chance
I had this goal that by the time he was
18 I would have transformed our lives
and I ran hard for it and I worked hard
for it and by the time he was 18 our
lives were completely transformed and
barely recognizable
and I found that I had slowed down a bit
still running but running at about 70%
and the challenge that you have to watch
out for is that your 70% could be
someone else's a hundred and fifteen
percent because you are such a game
changer so you can impress a lot of
people never playing full-out and you
can look up in the years past three
years past five years have passed and
you haven't played full out for a while
because you've already achieved a lot by
some people's standards but there's
still so much more that you can do I
want to coach you in this way dream a
dream are set a goal that's big enough
to make you get nervous often times if
you're not setting a goal that's beyond
three years out in front of you there's
not enough to run for so I want you to
look at your goals can you achieve them
in a year two years I want you to set a
goal for three years set a goal for five
years and set a goal for ten years yes I
said ten years when I did this
phenomenal program called life book they
had me set ten-year goals and I was so
uncomfortable I said they're silent for
a moment I hadn't thought ten years out
about my life but if you go out far
enough ten five three then all of a
sudden you're playing for something so
much bigger and then set a goal that
makes your knees knock and your teeth
chatter a bit if you know how to get to
your goal you're not dreaming big enough
now the goal also has to be realistic so
has to be realistic something you can do
if you're currently making 80,000 then
your goal in three years isn't to make
500,000 unless you have a path that's
viable to get you there that's real the
thing that's really important to
remember about a goal is that if you set
lofty goals that you will never hit
because they're not realistic in the
first place you have to set realistic
goals that doesn't mean you're not
capable doesn't mean that you don't
believe in yourself but realistic goals
if you set a bunch of unrealistic goals
and you don't hit them every time you
don't need a goal you lose just a little
bit of hoping yourself a little bit of
faith in yourself and then what happens
is you look up five years ten years from
now and you're not dreaming anymore
you're not setting goals anymore you're
afraid to tell anyone so set a goal that
makes your knees knocking your teeth
chatter a bit set a goal that's three
years out in front of you set one that's
five years and set one that's ten years
and matter of fact sets several and all
those timelines and then hook your
caboose to the Train of other people who
are running as fast as you are surround
yourself in a community that inspires
you to want to stand on your tippy toes
they inspire you because they're doing
so much now they believe in values they
believe in faith they believe in family
but they also believe in running hard
playing hard and living big because if
you're the biggest fish in your
community then that's okay you just need
to get a second community to play inside
them as well and so if you find yourself
going hold on I've become complacent
walk out 15 years and go do I want to
look back in 15 years and this was the
best that I did the answer probably is
no rule number 20 live your quest when
we talk about living our quest I think
that living my quest really if I look at
on a daily basis it's finding my own
voice it's finding your voice it's
finding the song that only you can sing
off-key or not it's finding your rhythm
it's discovering what it feels like to
walk in your shoes today it won't look
like it looked ten years ago
living your quest is what can I do with
my life so that my life becomes
infectious to someone else living my
quest looks like how do I make my
fingerprint matter so big that it lives
beyond my transition day living your
quest is how can I forgive the
perceiving Lea unforgivable so I can
love the absolute loveable
living your quest is how do I give
myself a thousand second chances and
every time I get to 999 press reset yeah
yeah living my quest is is not some
ambiguous untouchable experience living
my quest means going back and healing
the little girl in me so that the woman
can be free it's going back at embracing
the little boy in you so that the man
can show up and give himself permission
to cry when necessary living your quest
is not something that you can't touch
it's not something that requires a stage
or lights or cameras living your quest
as being completing content with who you
are in the dark of the night so who you
are in the middle of the day is all
right
living your quest is as simple as it is
complex living your quest is about
giving yourself permission say
permission on a daily basis to become
the next best version of yourself living
your quest is not holding yourself
hostage to old decisions not holding
yourself hostage to shame blame guilt
regret and anger living your quest is
about recognizing that everyday I can be
reborn to my possibility living your
quest is as internal and personal as it
is public living your quest is about
recognizing that you have brilliance in
you and not being willing to dim your
light one more day living your quest
means not being afraid of the genius in
you even though you have doubt living
your quest is recognizing that you get
to sing your song off tune that you can
get to live in perfection while you
master imperfection rule number 21 shift
your energy we spend so much time and
energy trying to prevent ourselves from
falling we spend so much energy trying
to prevent a failure we spend so much
energy making sure were safe
and if we spent 70% of that energy
exploring how we can soar exploring how
we can play bigger explore how we can
make memories that we absolutely will be
excited to tell when we're 85 years old
sitting in our favorite rocking chair if
we spent 40% 50% of that same energy how
would our lives look differently I'm not
saying be reckless I'm not saying do it
without a plan what I am saying is so
many times I get the question how do I
prevent failure and I'd love for you to
spend that same energy going how could I
ensure that I soar how can I ensure that
I live the life that I want to tell
people about that I write the story
that's gonna be really really good to
read so number one is shift your energy
on what you want to create versus what
you want to prevent because energy grows
where energy goes if you've looked at
several episodes you've probably heard
me say that before
not because I've run out of content but
because I want to keep saying it because
repetition is not the mother and father
of learning repetition is the mother
father sister brother aunt and uncle and
second cousin of learning so I'm going
to keep telling you this that energy
grows where energy goes so while we want
to mitigate and reduce our risk of
falling reduce our risk of failure we
want to spend our dominant energy on
creating possibility and what we want to
run toward now I say that I say that
from lessons learned not just as a
teacher but because I for many years in
the early part of my career unbeknownst
to me unconsciously I wasn't running
toward possibility I was trying to
outrun eleven dollars and 42 cents in
the bank like I had in 1994 and so I
know that once I was able to get far
enough away from that experience I start
losing motivation I stopped running as
fast I didn't know it I didn't know
why it's because I knew I wasn't
threatened by ever seeing $11 and 42
cents again and then I brought all my
motivation was gone I was nervous for
about a year I was still in motion still
you know generating a lot of business a
lot of buzz but internally I wasn't
driven the same way until I shifted my
energy and said what am i running toward
the first answer was I don't know
because I've been trying to outrun
something so long but I wasn't looking
forward really looking for like horizon
for like up for I may have been looking
at the next goal for it the next target
for but I wasn't looking at horizon
something so big it would take me ten
years to get there it would take me 15
years to get there and so number one
let's create a big bodacious like Yummie
in five years I want to be here in ten
years I want to have this let's create
something to run toward that makes your
knees knock a bit then it stretches you
it doesn't stress you it stretches you
rule number 22 live in alignment of your
purpose I love the phrase willpower but
willpower isn't something you conjure up
willpower isn't something you drink
willpower isn't something you download
from Google what you're talking about is
how do I make the choices that are in
alignment with my highest purpose and my
highest vision for myself that's what
you really want to ask see your life is
a physical manifestation of the choices
that you made up into this moment I'm
gonna say that again because that gets a
little deep and that can go over some
people's head that can hit you sometimes
right between the eyes and you got to
hear the second time so here goes your
life right now as it exists to
your finances your weight your
relationships your career your
self-esteem your self-image your
spiritual awareness all of that is a
result of the choices that you've made
up into this moment big and small and
just so you know your life the way it
appears today is not a result of a few
big choices even though that's the thing
that we look back on we go oh I
shouldn't have moved out of the state oh
I shouldn't I got into that relationship
oh I shouldn't have we look at the big
things well I'm here to disrupt that
mindset a bit your life experience right
now is not so much a result of your big
choices why those impact you it's really
a result of a bunch of small little
choices made consistently over a long
period of time because those are the
habits and the behaviors that you've
gotten into so we can talk about
willpower and how do I build willpower
as if it's something that you can flex
in the gym or something you can do
crunches or abs or triceps and build but
it's not the question you should ask the
answer you should be seeking is what
does it take to make my choices become
an alignment with the life that I say I
want to live
now when you say choices it makes it
really sobering because even when you
choose to sit down on yourself it was a
choice so I ask you in this moment what
will it take you to decide to make the
choice today don't even think about
tomorrow don't think about next week but
to make the choice today that's in
alignment with your health goals make a
choice today that's in alignment with
your financial goals it's the small
things it's the extra visit to Starbucks
it's the extra biscuit it's the getting
up early it's 10 more crunches it's
doing squats every time you go to the
bathroom at least that's what I do I do
10 I do 10 every time I go to the
restroom I'm already there I'm just
gonna keep on going just because I want
to stay in alignment with my goal and my
goal is to have a body that at least
creates a double tank or or triple date
maybe I don't know I wanted to create a
body that is in alignment with my goal I
want to be able to go paintballing with
my nephews and my son the way I just did
recently I want to be able to go jet
skiing so when I look at my life in my
lifestyle that I want to maintain it
requires me to hike a little longer it
requires me to eat more vegetables and
protein it requires me my choice of how
I want to live requires my alignment and
what I put in my body or how I stay
active in my body so when I date I don't
I don't do dinner dates I'm not
interested in doing dinner dates you
want to date me let's go on a hike let's
go skating ice skating roller skating is
going to walk
I want active dates in my dating
experience because that's an alignment
with my life's purpose so what are you
choosing let's not even look at
willpower let's look at choices because
choice is something you can control in
every single moment and the choice you
made yesterday if it wasn't alignment
with your greatest goal and your highest
purpose okay yesterday yesterday make a
new choice today you're not ever
condemned or sentenced to making the
same choice over and over and over again
every day every moment you have a new
opportunity to make a new choice rule
number 23 stay in the moment I know as
an entrepreneur you know there's so many
years where I worked the day away the
night away but way beyond working the
damn the night away I worked memories
away I worked parts of my life away
I worked sacred moments away I want to
warn you I want to warn you about
working so hard to create an amazing
future that you miss a million nails so
busy creating that future where your
children or your family or your parents
or your significant other will have
everything they want
in the moment you're robbing them from
the one thing they need you your time I
know that our intentions are good and I
say ours cuz I'm right there with you
I would grind every day in my walk-in
closet I transform my walk-in closet
until my office
I would walk my son to school come back
put my head down my elbows up and I
would come up for air just enough to
walk the school pick him up bring him
back fix him a fast lunch I go back down
and then I come back up at dinnertime
and then I go back down and I did it for
a year after year after year after year
and I looked up and I forgot the things
I like I forgot the the excursions that
I want to go and I forgot my favorite
food cuz my favorite food was whatever
was fastest and quickest and can get me
back to work I thought that the
sacrifice was okay that it's okay to
sacrifice at this level and Wow there is
a necessary sacrifice there is a
necessary level of inconvenience
there also is a required and oh by all
means
a desired amount of memories that you
want to make sure you make now I wrote
my book abundance now and I remember
having conversations with the publishers
and others about the now you know
because whether it was abundant life or
abundance and prosperity or abundance
beyond the secret another title it was
important for me to write abundance now
because there's nothing more valuable
than your now so yes I'm going to
encourage you to work hard I'm going to
encourage you to grind but I'm gonna
remind you that when you're sitting in
your rocking chair and there's nothing
else for you to do you have played
full-out you've made all the money
you're going to make you've bought all
the properties you're gonna buy you've
done all the business you can do and
you've attended all the meetings there
are to attend and all that's left to do
now
is to sit inside your memories you're
gonna want to have a lot of really great
memories rule number 24 don't live under
the label they so often we wear labels
there's a label that's to me there's
several labels I'm an african-american
woman I'm a single mom you know I'm a
CEO I'm a daughter there's so many
labels to me but I don't live under the
label I allow the label to exist but it
doesn't define me and so I invite you if
you're a woman you know there's so many
men watching my channel I love you I
want you to always come you're always
welcome this is your home but to my
sisters I invite you don't feel like
life is harder for you because you're a
woman don't feel like you have to work
harder because your woman work hard just
work hard I never looked at and while
working harder as a woman and my working
harder as a black person now are there
inequities absolutely I am NOT blind to
that but like I said in the previous
episode energy grows or energy goes
am I gonna give the inequities energy or
I'm not going to give the possibilty
energy and I'm not saying that
everything's hunky-dory and all things
are right no there are some wrongs that
really need to be corrected but here's
what I won't do I won't wear a label and
walk in a room living under that label
wondering how you're going to treat me
because of that label people used to ask
Lisa how did you get on the main stage
with people like Tony Robbins and and
Jack Canfield and people like you know
they rattle off all these older white
men are very successful white speakers
in the industry and they say how'd you
get on stage with them as a black woman
or how did you get on stage with them as
a woman
and I go I didn't get on stage with him
as a woman I got on stage with them as a
badass speaker I got on stage with them
as someone who can bring value to the
audience I got on stage with them
because I'm a change agent
so can you live through the results that
you produce in the world can you allow
that to define you like this is the bag
that you were given a woman a man black
white Indian Asian the religion you were
born into the economic status should
grew up under all of those things are
boxes that someone else said let's drop
you in it and then you have to choose if
you're gonna stay in it I am too big to
be defined by a box any box any label of
any size why don't you join that so
don't be successful as a woman be
successful
don't be successful as a man be
successful
don't be loving and giving as a black
person or white person or asian person
be loving and giving just be and then be
become contagious for someone else to
want to be that way because they crossed
your path
rule number 25 do what you love to do so
many times we've become so dutiful
working and being diligent and being
responsible and being on point that we
forgot to do the things that bring us
joy you know as I was developing my
business I thought I was doing the thing
that I love the most which was
transforming lives and talking to teens
and inspiring teens inspiring adults but
I forgot that I love to dance
I forgot that I love to hang out I
forgot that I loved a date I forgot
about so many things
so our traded one love for all these
other little things and I was being
responsible as a mom
responsible as a business owner
responsible as a daughter and yet my
norm have become filled with all the
dutiful things in my life and not the
things that necessarily brought me the
most joy while my family brings me great
joy my work bring brings me a great joy
there was a part of me that was slowly
dying away just because it was unfair so
let's make a list of what do you love to
do what do you love to do and then let's
set an intention that don't try to do it
all the time I think we go to the
extremes once a week I'm gonna do this
or you can't go from zero to once a week
but start from zero from once a month
and so your norm is whatever you decided
to be you aren't the designer of your
destiny and you are the author of your
autobiography and no one can write your
story but you life isn't happening to
you
you're co-creating you are the main
character you you wrote the screenplay
this is your life and how you look at it
and the lenses that you look at your
life through has everything to do with
how much you enjoy it or not
rule number 26 give yourself permission
to fail so often you don't move forward
because you're keeping such score from
what didn't work in the past you are
holding yourself hostage to 1997 to 2005
you're holding yourself hostage in love
to that past relationship that didn't
work or you're holding yourself in
hostage in business to the money that
you may have thought you wasted or the
deal that went bad and so one of the
ways I give myself permission for two
two levels permission to have lived a
life that has some beautiful experiences
and some really tangy lessons I mean
they're spicy they hurt they're painful
when I give myself permission to have
had that I also give myself permission
to keep leaping give myself permission
to keep dreaming give myself permission
to keep learning how to get it right
learning how to love the unlovable
forgive what seems to be the
unforgivable to leap again even while I
still have a bandage on my chin from the
time I fell I still get to lead someone
invite you if you fall fall catch your
breath
put a bandage on it whether you fail
financially you fail physically with
health and wellness you felt spiritually
you fell emotionally you felt in a
relationship okay a part of flying is
understanding what the distinction
between flying and falling and the only
way you understand the distinction is
that you experience full life when you
experience full life it's like this life
isn't just flatline is not just like
this you make your Heights feel better
because you understand this was a
failure and and what I mean by a failure
is this taught me a lesson this stung
this every single failure has a lesson
in it to me a failure is a lesson
wrapped in some sticky icky paper that
stung that hurt and so give yourself
permission give yourself permission to
play big to be nervous to fall down to
sit down for a minute just don't take up
real estate in the sitting down don't
take up real estate in the analyzing
don't take some don't take up real
estate in the preparation you've been
getting prepared for a long time for
something trust that you'll either fly
if you leap right now or your fall if
you leave right now and if you fly
you'll understand what soaring feels
like and if you fall you'll understand
what getting up feels like either way
you're okay that's how I play big with
my knees knocking that's how I play big
even when there's something in my in my
consciousness reminding me of the last
time I did something like this and it
didn't quite work out and I still play
big because I gave myself I give myself
I constantly give myself permission to
totally win and soar are totally falling
it up
and that way there's nothing to truly be
afraid of remember this is a dialogue
not a monologue which means we're in a
dynamic conversation versus me just
entertaining you rule number 27 ask
better questions you know I've worked
with thousands hundreds of thousands of
people and Trust is always at the top of
the list
coach show me how to trust again coach
what happens when I've been betrayed
coach show me how to trust myself again
Trust is a gift and when our trust is
violated by any form we feel like a
little bit of it's been chipped away but
here's what I want to let you know Trust
is something that can be restored and
Trust is something that people can earn
and Trust is something that you have
enough of it always hurts my heart when
I hear someone say I don't trust I don't
trust because what I know is you're not
trusting your future something or
someone in your future because of
something that happened in your past and
in so many ways you're making your next
pay for your ex you're making your
future pay for your past you're making
that unexperienced moment pay for that
past experience more deserves to be
loved and honored and celebrated to full
capacity than you and if you don't stick
your feet fully in then you can't fully
feel submerged and the possibility is
there a chance that this person that
you're in this relationship with now
this friendship without this business
appointment with now this this community
relationship now is there a chance that
they may not play full out and honor you
yes but here's what I know you don't
want to do you don't want to have a
of saying I played half way I stuck my
toe in instead of jumping in so you want
to do your due diligence one of the
things I learned from my years of living
trusting being betrayed hurting crying
praying laughing getting back up
and being committed to love again trust
again was that any time that I felt
betrayed anytime that I felt like
someone didn't honor me there was a part
that I played in that experience there
was a better question that I could have
asked sooner there was a clear line that
I could have drawn way deeper in the
sand there was a notice of intuition or
there was a tap on the shoulder that I
was the alarm clock was going off there
was something that I could have seen
said or done that I was a viable part of
this equation now I own the part that's
mine and I own the part that's not mine
but how I bring that forward and how I
recommend you bring it forward is ask
better questions now you're not the same
person you were three years ago five
years ago ten years ago you're not the
same person you were last year ask a
better question and you'll get a better
answer rule no 28 have a no matter what
attitude it began to shift from me when
I move from optional to non-negotiable
when I move from I really really want
this to hold on this is non-negotiable
it's time for me to move from I'd like
it to happen to no matter what it has to
happen no matter what
Jelani has to have the type of
opportunities that normally an
african-american male child from South
Central LA whose father went to prison
when he was 8 months old wouldn't have
CI had to become non negotiable that
Jelani has a breathtaking future I had
to become non negotiables say no matter
what that I was gonna get off government
assistance and not only was I gonna get
off government assistance that I was
gonna create a healthy lifestyle around
money finances and fiscal success and
responsibilities I had to say no matter
what around creating the life that I
love where I can travel the world and
inspire people I had to say no matter
what around keeping my family intact and
keeping my relationships intact
I did that I had to say no matter what
around my health and my wellness and
bringing back physical prosperity to my
life into my body nothing happened and
so I went from optional to
non-negotiable to no matter what when I
came to no matter what that's when the
mountain if it was in front of me it had
to bow down and have to move and so I
believe that you're in the exact same
place that as you move into next year
you're at a no matter what time you're
at a non-negotiable time you're at a
move every other option off the table
rule number 29 fake it until you make it
I know the whole fake it till you make
it well I don't want to fake it forever
I have no interest in faking it forever
but I do want to play like I'm
courageous enough until my courage
appears I want to pretend like I'm not
afraid until I'm not afraid I want to
fake like I know how to do this business
I know how to surrender to this love and
while pursuing the ability to know how
to do this business pursue the
understanding of knowing how to
surrender to love I don't think there's
a place in your life that when you're
playing bigger than you've played before
that you won't feel nervous you won't
feel a little afraid and at times you
won't have a sense of the imposter
syndrome
what if what if you're not an imposter
and the career you're in you're not an
imposter in the relationship you're not
imposter and the entrepreneurial
business what if what if you're just
learning what if you visualize the
seven-foot-tall you
and the five eight six one six two five
two version of you is still tippy-toe
undergrow to that individual rule number
38 your action you are not a victim to
anything there is not something that's
been bestowed upon your family that
generationally has to occur over and
over and over again there are habits
there are awareness and there are
actions and when you change your habits
expand your awareness and elevate your
action you can change a curse into a
blessing
rule number 31 take baby steps you're
gonna play big say big you're gonna play
huge say huge you're gonna play
ginormous say ginormous but first take
baby steps you gonna eat the elephant
but take one small bite first chew it
good right we want so much so fast my
grandmother says baby she starts every
sentence with baby I'm sure it's because
she cannot remember all of our names she
said baby the best things you'll ever
have from Grandma will never come from
the microwave they always come from the
oven and I was like I think some somehow
she's trying to give me a lesson here
and I realized that the best things that
you're gonna create are gonna take time
build it on cement not sinking saying
you're gonna get tons and tons and tons
of tools here and you're gonna want to
fast forward when you fast forward
you're building on Plexiglas you've been
on styrofoam you've been on wood you
want to build it on semen your dream is
important enough to outlive you yes yes
and so I realized that that you can't
Google download resiliency you can't
Google download tenacity you can't
Google download forgiveness there are
some of the best qualities and
characteristics that's gonna take you a
long way that you need to invest time in
and energy in and intention in you don't
just get patience I want patience I'm
waiting for pick somebody's gonna piss
you off tomorrow then now you get to
test of your patience
I realized I realized that as I wanted
to develop me I have to be willing to
climb and I wanted to get to the top and
there's no elevator to the top I got to
do my squats I got to work on my quads
and my hamstrings and my calves cuz I
gotta climb to the top
we got a Klein rule number 32 change
your relationship with fear so many
people look at fear or even doubt but
they look at fear as if it's the
emotional enemy you know it's the enemy
emotion like oh I can deal with
compassion I can do it love I can do it
understanding but when fear comes oh my
god bad thing No first of all change
your relationship to fear I've said this
before fear is not the enemy the feeling
of fear is just like any other emotion
fear is actually informing you fear is
telling you that you need to do
something either do more research get
some support get some insight study a
little more slow down fear is actually
feeding you so then ask yourself the
question what do I need to do think or
go get to dissipate this fear because
remember fear is fear becomes present
when you've made up something that could
happen in the future and it makes you
afraid now like oh my god I'm afraid I
can get hurt in this relationship oh my
god I'm afraid I'll lose my money well
you're just projecting a story that you
made up then back into that fear go okay
wait then what do I need to do to
minimize the fear that I might get hurt
what do I need to do to minimize the
fear that I might lose my money what do
I need to do of course you can't a 100%
eliminate the possibility but you can
greatly reduce the chances by asking
what am i afraid of what am i afraid
that's gonna happen and then secondly
recognize that fear doesn't mean stop
people think oh I'm afraid let me stop
okay that's a choice to stop fear
doesn't necessarily mean stop fear might
mean proceed with caution or proceed
with more strategy fear does it whenever
I'm feeling fear it doesn't
tell me why don't you think now - stop
with the fear I do think to slow down go
get some help go get some inside voice
my fear so that it's not just all in my
head
recognize that fear is going to come in
when you're playing bigger than you've
ever played before I say if your knees
aren't knocking and your teeth are
chattering just a little at least then
you're not playing big enough the bigger
you play the more you're gonna feel your
knees knock and you don't hear your
teeth chatter and I'm always playing big
I'm always filling my knees knock and
I'm always hearing my teeth chatter but
I've created a relationship with that
fear to go hold on let's say fears right
here fear
what are you telling me because fear
really is it's it's a story it's it's
something you think could happen and
could it happen yeah but could it not
happen yeah so don't try to outrun fear
don't try to outrun doubt and definitely
don't wait into doubt and fear are gone
before you move find out what doubt and
fear needs to dissipate into the
nothingness that it always was what does
it need and then understand that action
brings clarity so the more you move
forward the more action you're in the
more clarity you get because action
breeds clarity and clarity comes with
action so many times just sitting on the
sidelines waiting waiting to get
completely clear before you take any
action and clarity is waiting for you to
get an action to create clarity so be
willing be willing to play full out a
little nervous
rule number 33 accept yourself I
remember there was a time in my life
when all I wanted was for people to
accept me but I realized that I needed
them to accept me
and love me because I wasn't really
accepting Lisa I wasn't really loving
Lisa to my fullest so while today I
don't invite you to not care if people
reject you I am inviting you to if you
fully love and show up for you first
then you're less impacted you're less
disrupted when someone doesn't embrace
you the way you believe you should be
embraced so you I realize that we're
we're ironed for others iron sharpens
iron
we're also triggers for others there's a
thousand reasons why someone might
reject you my grandmother says man's
rejection is God's protection so not
everyone that's in your space should be
in your space and sometimes people have
to opt out on your behalf to help you
out how many times have you been in a
friendship or relationship and it ended
and maybe not immediately after it ended
but somewhere in the next 30 60 90 days
a year maybe two years you took a deep
breath ah
[Music]
I actually feel more relief that that
relationship is transition where there's
a relationship with a job a friend an ex
whatever so while we don't want to have
rejection our life I say all rejection
isn't bad and sometimes it's not
rejection is simply transition it's
simply completion you know I realize
that I wanted everyone to love me but
when I began to love Lisa I stopped
having to manage or having the desire to
manage how other people like me your job
is to wake up each day and like you rule
number 34 be in a state of cognitive
dissonance abundant thinkers keep
themselves in a constant state of
cognitive dissonance write that down
abundant thinkers keep themselves in a
constant state a constant state of
cognitive dissonance your creative spell
it any way you want now what is
cognitive dissonance cognitive
dissonance is
you have literally thought about a
version of yourself that you're not
currently living right now
meaning the thought that you have of
yourself your behaviors are not
congruent with so your mind becomes
disrupted your mind says wait a minute
you're seeing me here but my behaviors
aren't here and when you keep yourself
in a constant state your mind begins to
influence your behaviors to be congruent
with your thoughts ooh
next level cognitive dissonance abundant
thinkers that's why he went out to the
ocean that's why he's up on stage
because constantly seeing himself
further than what his behaviors want to
really do and then when he does it now I
got that down constantly now it's being
grateful for your now yes yes being
grateful for your now but clearly seeing
where you're going and not resting until
you get there rule number 35 practice
gratitude I start every day with 25
things that I'm grateful for and all 25
things have to cost $25 or less so I
can't be grateful for my car grateful
for my home while I can be grateful
during this exercise I'm grateful for
the time that I spent cooking him in the
kitchen with my son this weekend I'm
grateful for the walks that my
grandmother takes me on I used to say I
take her on walks then I realized she
was educating me that she takes me on
walks I'm grateful for the fact that I
still dance with my daddy I'm grateful
for the moments my nephew climbs in my
bed so we can watch our latest greatest
movie together I'm grateful for mustard
man and garlic girl in the kitchen
cooking that's my son and I every single
thing that I find gratitude for is
something that helps to make me who I am
and I got to tell you something happens
when you live Park and stay cement it in
gratitude I call that if your dream is
the seed then gratitude is the
fertilizer and so gratitude constant
gratitude recognizing that you are a
servant leader with a servant's heart
and when you say the word servant
servant and ego just don't go together
servant is too
but not a servant from a peasant mindset
but a servant from the place where you
say I choose to leave from behind I
choose to use my greatness and my life
to elevate you I choose to own my life
but hand it over to anyone who might
need it in the moment if you stay rooted
in that it's a daily thing so I
recommend that you find the daily
regimen that keeps you steeped in
gratitude a daily regimen that has you
owned your greatness where there's the
reminder of the things I've just said
write the mantras out post them on your
mirror and recite them each day I live
by mantras I live by affirmations I
designed and begin to own who I was as a
woman because I kept reminding myself
daily who I could become and then one
day I want to remind myself and it's
stuck I didn't need the reminder and so
I start to remind myself of something
else and I kept doing that daily daily
and then one day I want to remind myself
in it stuck and so remind yourself of
the woman the man you're becoming write
it down write the mantra down I'm a
servant leader grateful for service I
own my brilliance unapologetically I
walk in a room and light it up with a
natural glow I share my life with others
with grace and ease you can choose any
of these mantras you can have them all
rule number 36
recognize the cost of your actions so
many times people look at the habits
that they have such as procrastination
and asked why do I procrastinate well I
pose that question back to you ask
yourself what's the benefit because
there's a benefit that you're getting
out of it so whether you believe that
last minute throws you inside of an
energy source because that's what I used
to think I spent last minute I'm more
creative well the truth is you're not
more creative last minute the truth is
that when you wait to the last minute
you're increasing your stress level
you're bringing down your joy you're
eliminating peace of mind when you
understand the cost procrastination is a
word and the challenge is that
procrastination is so universally
accepted it's like fear and stress like
I'm so stressed out and it's become such
our norm that it's okay
well ask
yourself the question what's the price
that I pay cuz I believe any behavior
that you don't want any longer the way
that the catalysts of change is
recognizing the price because we're high
producers we can still get it done
inside of procrastinating we can still
get it done but if you ever take a
moment to stop and ask yourself an
answer what's the cost of me
procrastinating and you can do that for
everything but we're focused on
procrastination now what's the cost of
me procrastinating let's go down that
list
I mean you procrastinate it costs you
clear organizational time because now
you're rushing when you procrastinate it
cost you peace of mind when you
procrastinate you're now thrown in
urgency urgency increases your stress
urgency is known to increase your stress
if you live in urgency you literally are
two three times more likely to have a
heart attack
I hear not confirm but that's what I
heard so if you live in this pace of
urgency all the time because of a
behavior that you can modify think about
it how are we for moving a bully mobile
how are we brilliant and operating in
something we can control
there's so many things that you can't
control procrastination is something
that you can go draw rule number 37 have
patience patience is that thing that you
know all of us want but we don't know
how to get the patience to get it it's
that it's that gift in that character
that's only developed in the discomfort
of the act of patience itself you know
I'm going to share a couple of stories
with you because I have had more bouts
with being impatient than anything to
the point now that I think one of the
one of the characters that's the most
developed in me is the character of
patience I recognize that if not now it
will happen but mine now does not mean
never minds when it's supposed to happen
and my job is to stay in action you know
I was sitting in the van
on my way to a good friend's house I was
sitting in the van with many other
teachers from the secret way back in
2008 and many many things were happening
and a lot of success was going on but I
was still struggling so on the outside I
had notoriety I was in the secret we
have been on Oprah and so many things
were happening but on the inside
personally I was still trying to figure
out how to pay my car note I was still
trying to figure out how to you know
take care of my son while I'm on the
road I still had all these challenges
that really did not make me feel like I
was successful and I felt like I
couldn't work another hour of the day I
couldn't put forth any more energy I
couldn't do anything else and I've been
doing it so long I've been grinding so
long you might know what I what that
looks like I was sitting in a van on my
way to John Gray's house a minute from
Mars myrfor mean it's a good friend of
mine and it was so many of us in the van
and I remember looking over at my friend
John Assaraf and I asked I said John why
doesn't have to be so hard why do I have
why is it taking so long I feel like
I've been at this forever
and I don't see any result I'm tired I'm
exhausted I feel like I'm about to lose
faith in this dream and John turned to
me and he said something that just
shifted everything for me and I hope it
does the same for you he looked at Manny
said Lisa you cannot plant your seeds
and reap your harvest
and the same season rule number 38 and
Hank's your enrichment I'm only gonna go
as far as you think you're worthy I can
push you can push you can have the
greatest product but if you don't feel
worthy you will work hard to sabotage
that relationship you don't know you
don't know you're doing you think these
are the things I need and you're driving
that guy away you're driving that woman
away because your self-worth says they
weren't gonna stay forever anyway
or I'm self-worth around money you have
a cat that you feel like you're worthy
of a million dollars you will always get
to 999 thousand and you will stop
because your self-worth says it what's a
good exercise or process that we can
follow on a daily basis maybe something
simple to enhance our enrichment
absolutely worthiness absolutely I did
this for six months every single day
right after I brush my teeth and it's
the ICU exercise and you get in the
mirror now it is not necessarily simple
because because you dealing with
yourself of course and as complicated as
you are will be the degree economic
summit of Jebel mechanics are yes I
appreciate that distinction um you get
in the mirror and you complete three
different sentences you want to write
this down the first sentence you look at
yourself and you say your name so you
would say Louis and you complete this as
I'm proud that you and find seven
different things every day to celebrate
yourself for seven different each day
you can do the same thing you did the
day before
but each day do seven different things
to be proud of the second sentence is
gonna knock you down a little bit it's
gonna come from your gut Louis I forgive
you for and cut the shackles to blame
shame guilt regret and anger in that
sentence you cut those five shackles not
the first day maybe not the third day
but by the 21st day by the thirteenth
day you'll feel some relief so Louis I
forgive you for and go back five years
15 years 20 years do that forgive you
fit for that thing don't nobody know
about but you go ahead and cut those
shackles because if you can still think
about it is still in your energy space
and then the third sentence is Louis I
commit to you that before you make a
commitment to anybody else throughout
your day you make seven commitments to
you so the first sentence I'm proud that
you you're celebrating yourself first we
are under celebrate
as a society we look for acknowledgment
they enter they interviewed a hundred
executives that all made over a quarter
of a million dollars and said would you
like a five percent raise next year or
would you rather be told thank you more
often 100 percent 100 percent said keep
your money I'd rather hear thank you so
we're under celebrated but first
celebrate you be the example when I was
on Oprah when she said what do you do I
said I recognize that I'm the example of
how the rest of the world is supposed to
treat me and it's my job to give the
world the best example of how I like to
be treated right so celebrate yourself
forgive yourself cut the shackles and
then commit to yourself before you
commit to anyone else that right there
powerful that right there will begin to
fill your cup up mmm to get to your
sausage I love that rule number 39
exercise your know our desire to say yes
to everyone really is less about them
and more about our need to be approved
our need to be perceived loving kind and
generous now I know that might be hard
to hear but when you don't have the
ability to say no it really isn't about
the people that you're saying no to it's
about you not wanting to draw healthy
boundary not wanting to turn someone
away not wanting to risk the fact that
you might not make someone happy with
you in the moment go underneath that and
say why am I having that challenge the
answer to that is the core of why you
don't want to say no because I want to
be liked and loved all the time
because I don't want to experience
rejection because I want people to see
me as a giving loving person because
because because because now none of
those are wrong but can you already know
that about yourself and if you know
you're loving if you know you're kind if
you know you're giving if you know that
you're generous then you can say healthy
yeses when you need to say yes and you
can say i healthy know when you need to
say no my grandmother says if you want
your yes to have the most value possible
then sweetie you need to learn how to
massage you know because if you keep
telling everyone yes you actually
diminish the value of your yes because
I'm not grateful that you said yes as a
matter of fact I expected you to say yes
why because you always say yes
rule number 40 fund your dream in that
year when I was really broke and I was
really broken I was working at LA
Unified School District I was miserable
I was miserable because I wasn't living
in my dream I was just doing a J OB
and then one day I said well what what
do I need to do I I need to I need to
buy my freedom
that's not either don't hate to buy her
freedom well I don't know about behind
my freedom I don't know about buying I
don't know about having money saved up
my family didn't have money saved up my
mother used to tell me all this money is
burning my pocket so I know two things
about money is hot and we can't keep it
long we'd always have one week where we
had all the food in the refrigerator and
then one week where we were the
refrigerator was empty right come on
come on some of you guys know about that
to this day I spent so much money on
girls you guys oh my god it's like I'm
feeding like a family of ten because I'm
so afraid of anybody ever being in my
house and being hungry and so I I wrote
a check to myself
Jelani was three a hundred and ten
dollars I took it to the bank Wells
Fargo
I started a new account the next check I
wrote a hundred and twenty five dollars
and just like the first check I put in
the minimum line funding my dream
I wasn't even clear what the dream was
but I knew there was something in my
belly who in this room know you got
something in your belly it's something
I'm not even clear about it I don't know
how clear you are but I wasn't clear
about it but I knew there was a calling
on my life greater than working for LA
Unified School District and no
disrespect to LA Unified School get just
wasn't my destiny I wrote another check
in two weeks a hundred and forty six
dollars funding my dream now I started
mailing the checks in because I didn't
want to see my balance because I don't
want to go shopping cuz I you gonna
repeat what you learned right until you
decide to not repeat what you learned
so I mailed the check in and I wrote
another check and I wrote another check
if every check I wrote I made sure it
was five percent more than the first
check the net the previous check I sold
my Altima I had a car note so multiple
bought a clunker cuz it hadn't have a
car note now I can write a bigger check
son in my dream I moved out of my
three-bedroom three bed three bath house
and moved in became a roommate with my
friend who smoked
I put towels at the base of the door so
the smoke wouldn't come to the door I
was willing to be inconvenienced are you
I'm just saying I'm just I'm just
showing you the story I just took charge
I just gave you I stopped getting my
hair done that was when I started going
natural
I stopped going out I stopped going out
dancing I stopped going out to dinners
my family didn't know what was going on
they thought oh my god you know is La
she's on drugs but she's not losing
weight so maybe not I don't know what's
going on I kept writing bigger checks to
myself
$900 $900 I mailed it to Wells Fargo
funding my dream
$1100 melted to Wells Fargo funding my
dream I still wasn't clear what the
dream was I just knew I had one and it
was being born through me and I needed
to give it a chance that's all I knew
you don't have to see 2,000 feet in
front of you
just see 200 and run to the 200 don't
have to see it all three and a half
years later I've written a check to
myself every two weeks for three and a
half years I didn't go out for three and
a half years I didn't go dance and I get
to digging in my hair and I did get my
nails done for three and a half years
are you willing to be inconvenience for
your conviction I walk in to Wells Fargo
three and a half years later and I said
hi god bless you hi my name is Lisa
nickel she was oh my god you're the
funding my dream lady I was like yeah I
guess I am and all of a sudden all the
tellers came running around the manager
came they're like oh my god okay oh my
god we have been wondering we all got
the same question y'all know the
questions right what's your dream I was
like oh I'm not sure but I know that it
includes inspiring people having people
believe in themselves again teaching
them how to get back up when they've
been knocked down yep having to be
willing to give them self a thousand
second chances every time they get to
999 press reset I'm not sure what its
gonna look like but it's just gonna help
people I thought I came to check my
balance I've been writing a few checks
to you guys and say yes you've been
writing a lot I said I just want to
check my bounces you don't know your
bounces - no I got this really big stack
of summary bank statements at home cuz
my momma said money burns her pocket is
not a one
to burn my pocket I wanted to pay for my
freedom I said I just came to see what
my balance was if I had enough to fund
my dream as it gets clearer she wrote it
down everyone's excited she wrote it
down turned it around to me I looked at
it I said oh no my name is Lisa Shante
Nichols and my social security no I said
that is not my money and I am NOT taking
that money because you're probably gonna
want it back
so just fix that error right now and
they looked at me I said you really
don't think that's yours I said no my
family's never had $5,000 in the bank or
$10,000 in the bank that's sixty-two
thousand five hundred dollars in the
bank they said Miss Nichols and everyone
teared up the manager teared up the
tellers teared up they said Miss Nichols
whatever your dream is I think you can
fund it now I looked at my son Jelani
who now is five or six I said jeylani
our lifes are gonna be a little
different now baby
Jelani says yeah mommy can't we can't we
now go to McDonald's see for three years
I've been telling you Lani I'll make you
a Big Mac mama makes Big Macs better
than McDonald's and so began with a
hundred and ten dollar check so I don't
know what yours is I don't know what
your radical looks like for some of you
your radical was coming here right yes
yes and this is the beginning this is
the beginning of your radical this is
the this is the bet the next best step
this is the first step and so I just
stopped by to let you know you're on the
right path and and as you ramped up has
you ramped up you're going to have
questions you're gonna be afraid I do
more things afraid now than I do
fearless cuz the bigger you play the
bigger your breakdown
every single one of my errors in the
last five years have cost me six figures
like every single one every single one
of my errors has required me to call an
attorney like they're just big one cuz
I'm playing big I'm playing big so be
willing to go to the edge and this is
where you are here be willing to go to
the edge and not just lean over and feel
the breeze and watch the people jump and
watch them soar and look through the
windows at all the people were living
great lies don't just go to the edge and
feel it be willing to lean fill your
heartbeat fill it that let you know
you're alive they'll let you know you're
okay fear fuels you fear lets you know
go get more information fear let you
know step below later and study fear let
you know get up a little earlier fear
let you know ask for help fear is
informing you it's not stopping you it's
just another emotion like love and
compassion and gratitude we just made it
paralyze us see fear doesn't stop me
fear informs me and when you get
intimately connected with the fear I
feel it and I'm moving forward anyway I
feel it and I'm gonna love anyway I feel
it and I'm gonna invest in me anyway I
feel it and I'm gonna show up and play
anyway when you get connected with fear
it becomes your best friend and when you
spend on the edge you feel the breeze
you feel the fear and you leap anyway
rule number 41 be non-negotiable I
wasn't supposed to be here by many
people standard I wasn't supposed to be
here I wasn't qualified to be here
see I was that woman on government's
assistance in 1994 I was that woman on
WIC women infant and children in 1994 I
was there
couldn't afford to put pampers on my son
so I'll wrap them in a towel for two
days in 1995 I'm that woman so what
would get me to being a best selling
author times seven books running a
multi-million dollar company having my
company go public two years ago and
going from warefare to Wall Street it
would simply be being non-negotiable so
I just stopped by to check in if you're
willing to be non-negotiable if you're
willing to stop asking the world for
permission to be amazing to be brilliant
to be divine
stop asking the world for permission and
begin today to give the world notice see
ajit says something's gonna happen to
you while you're here and I love that
have an expectation on your life you
didn't come here for them to do you okay
oh geez I'm here do me know this is your
life your opportunity you're brilliant
see the doors have been open and now you
dance to your rhythm sing to your song
you play to your tune and all you need
to do is pick up a little bit here and
pick up a little bit there and then take
radical action and become non-negotiable
abundant thinkers live in non-negotiable
average thinkers live an optional mmm
average thinkers if I really would love
to have a new business but your
behaviors are not congruent what'd you
say you would love when you move from
optional to non-negotiable you slit you
slit every other option off the table
I wasn't interviewed a hundred and fifty
five times in five months
and the number-one question I was asked
was Lisa how did you go from public
assistance to go in public how did you
go from welfare to Wall Street how did
you build a multi-million dollar
business how did you do it and I look I
said I just slit every other option off
the table like I really did I slit every
other option said there was no other
option burn the ship burn the ships
don't go back there was no there was no
other option I didn't even I didn't have
a plan B it's a capital A our baby dam a
but is a if now or later but i'ma get it
once you get to that place something
happens the universe aligns with you
because you're so intentional rule
number 42 ignore what others think so
many people ask me on so many different
platforms how do I find the courage to
dot dot dot dot dot as if courage is
something outside of you
you don't look under the pillow at home
you don't look under your bed you don't
look in the glove compartment of your
car and go find courage so let me just
start off with saying you don't find
courage you cannot find courage you
choose to not allow the fear to manage
your choices so I know that sounds like
that's just like all want want Lisa but
I'm gonna always tell you the truth if I
told you how to find something that
means that you don't have it already I'm
not going to tell you how to find
something that's not lost the the
reality is when you are more consumed
with what other people's perception of
you then you are with your own truth you
will always feel like you're not enough
you will always feel like you're not
enough because no matter how far you
come no matter how far you go someone
will always believe that there's further
that you can go which they're true it's
truth so how do you how do you manage or
how do you have the courage to have
transformation without getting consumed
with other people's thoughts of your
perception of you you become more
committed to your own transformation
than you are to managing people's
perception of your life you become more
committed to the joy that's your
birthright that you know is your
birthright then you are trying to manage
people's perception rule number 43
celebrate yourself you know when I talk
about celebrating the journey that's a
that has many layers to it celebrating
the journey one means don't wait until
you've arrived somewhere to celebrate
yourself that's number one it
means that you're always going to be in
pursuit of something so don't wait to
you arrive to acknowledge yourself don't
wait to you arrive arrive because I
still haven't arrived like we don't
arrive anywhere like if you are waiting
to arrive somewhere before you celebrate
you oh my god it's gonna be a long long
life celebrating yourself along the way
inside the journey it is it is as big as
allowing others to celebrate your
greatness how many times do we minimize
someone else's acknowledgment of us you
know I hear it's so many I used to do it
all the time to people say oh my god
you're so great no no no I was no no no
no like you want them to run past the
compliment like you feel uncomfortable
well hold on celebrating yourself along
the way inside the journey is allowing
people to acknowledge you
rule number 44 set quarterly goals I
like to set quarterly goals instead of
annual goals I like to make them a bit
more bite-sized now i start with a big
bodacious scary hairy goal right then I
immediately release that goal and chunk
it down into four smaller goals that are
bite-sized digestible and palatable I
can measure them every 90 days you want
to be able to measure write this down
you want to be able to measure your
actions your goals and your milestones
every 90 days when you do that it allows
you to see how close on path you are
have you exceeded your own expectation
if you have a goal that this year I want
to make an additional forty five
thousand dollars all I make an
additional hundred thousand dollars and
you get to the first quarter and you're
thirty thousand dollars in you know
you're on path however if you have the
goal over the year I want to make an
additional hundred thousand dollars and
you get to the end of the first quarter
and you're at ten thousand dollars in
additional revenue you know you need to
do something you know you need to ramp
up or you know that this next season
this next time I need to make sure that
I'm doubling up on my revenue to hit
that goal versus getting to November and
realizing that your own
at $35,000 towards your hundred thousand
dollar additional revenue goal whatever
your goal is whether it's a hundred
thousand or where there's ten thousand
or where there's a million dollars in
addition or whether it's new
relationships or whether it's a social
media
rule number 45 have unwavering
confidence I get kicked out of college I
got kicked out of college my second year
because I didn't want to continue to run
track I took my team undefeated the
first year Wow and they went from not
having won a track meet in two years at
all to going undefeated in two in one
year you could attribute what allowed
you to lead the team to do that and one
or two insights what would it be I had
unwavering confidence did you cultivate
that or was it natural was it cultivated
at home or was it personally cultivated
my dad and my mom they they I don't know
if he was brainwashed or encouraged me
conquering anything yeah like bait bait
I wasn't opposition didn't scare me it's
never half scared me like I don't look
at how how big the mountain is if I can
climb it I go are we gonna climb it
and what do we need to climb that size
mountain you know measure if I can do
something based on the size of the
opposition you decide we're gonna do it
and then decide what to do for that
particular scenario very different
strategy rule number 46 act on your
ideas if you have a lot of ideas a lot
of things that you want to do a lot of
write them out and I make columns for
each one so I don't put them all
together because they're each on almost
like on separate islands which is why
you feel so fragmented or overwhelmed or
whatever that might be
so I write up make columns and then I
just put the idea at the top of the
column and I just write out everything
that I have in my head up up the idea
until I feel like oh okay I got that out
once I have them out then I attach a
time line to what I'm gonna start it
and ideally complete it now let's be
clear the timeline of when you're gonna
start and complete are going to move so
don't get stressed out about the
timeline you made it up I'm gonna say
that again when you create a timeline
you made it up which means you get to
modify what you made up at any given
time but I give myself a start and a
completion date now here's the key thing
there are things that I give a start
date to that I'm not even going to start
for two years for 18 months matter of
fact I'll do like let's say I'm in the
second quarter of this year I'll put in
one of those columns my start date is
the second quarter of next year so I
know I'm gonna get to it I know I'm
gonna get to it it's called what am i
doing now and what am I not doing now
but I'm doing it I'm just not doing it
now oh man I'm gonna tell you don't
sleep on that little nugget right there
I learned that from my coach Suzy Carter
that there's you're doing now and then
there's you're doing but not now so it's
on the calendar everything that you're
doing should be on the calendar
there's the doing now it has a place on
the calendar that you're actively in and
then there's a doing not now because
it's on the calendar so I have some
great projects I'm excited about I don't
start them for like another ten months
and then I put all my other projects on
it from these columns inside of these
current ten months and so now you are
doing it because you have a start date
but you're not overwhelmed with it
because it's not all vying for your
spacing your attention in the now rule
number 47 on your brilliance how can you
stay humble you know as you amass more
success how can you stay humble while
owning your brilliance I believe that
there's two very separate intentions
running here number one on your
brilliance don't question it you don't
have to grand eyes it you don't have to
you don't have to highlight it you don't
have to have your brilliance and your
talent spew over onto other people and
and and minimize their greatness when
you live in your light you don't have to
promote it or diminish it you simply
live in it I noticed a lot of times when
people are successful they have a
tendency to want to remind you that they
are successful they remind you in the
way they speak to you they remind you in
the fact that they're always coaching
you they remind you
whatever however the status thing that
they do to me that's not owning your
brilliance or your success that's trying
to prove it that's trying to remind you
of it and a lot of times people want to
remind you or prove to you something
when they're still wondering if it's
true so number one on your light
unapologetically I don't try to dim your
light nor should you try to turn it up
just let it be
rise the tie from who you're being rise
the tie from your service when I say nor
should you try to turn it up that's not
saying don't tap until the greatest
version of you that means don't
artificially try to turn it up so
everyone in the room knows that you're
great you don't have to do that you
don't have to say it you don't have to
announce it you don't have to try to
remind me of it just be it but by the
same token don't try to hide it
rule number 48 practice active self-care
practice active self-care that means
you're not talking about the spa that
you want to go to you're not talking
about the nap that you need to take
you're not talking about the weekend you
want to get away - you're actually doing
it so I want you to take a moment to
reflect and identify what rejuvenates
you now they're not it's not always
something huge something big something
ginormous but it's something that allows
you to write this down recalibrate your
energy what keeps your energy and come
so many times we're working out of
anxiety need or stress stress is the
number one killers the number one robber
of life and joy what do we do actively
what do you do actively that will
rejuvenate you what's available to you I
want you to write down a strategy about
how and when you'll make time for
self-care during this busy time rule
number 49 cut away the weeds I make the
best decision I could based on what I
knew in that moment and when I know more
I do more when I know better I do better
and I'm going to love me in every moment
when I look back at the decisions I made
ten years ago some of the people I dated
some of the money I've
Benten what i spent money on some of the
places I went I go what was I thinking
and the answer is I was I've made
decisions based on what I knew at that
time I'm outside now and you can hear
the Gartner's in the background they're
cutting away trees they're cutting away
dead limbs they're cutting away old
grass they're there they're there
they're mining the weeds and pulling
things out just like we should do in our
lives and some of those things that we
should take away are the the fear of
people's thoughts of us and what those
thoughts are going to show up as in our
lives listen what I know I love the
sound of all the machinery in the
background because that reminds me to
trim away to cut away allows the space
for new things to grow so sometimes you
have to cut away the need to be liked by
everybody the need to manage everyone
else's perceptions and thoughts of you
you have to cut it away like those
gardeners are cutting away dead leaves
like those gardeners are cutting away
the weeds the things that grow in
between the beautiful grass and between
the beautiful flowers they're things
growing up inside that's what's
happening in the middle of your
transformation other people's thoughts
other people's inconvenience if you want
to hold people want to hold you hostage
to the person they've always known you
to be you who what are these new
thoughts you have what are these the
things you're doing we don't know you
this way go back to the old you know be
more committed to the you that you're
becoming then you are to the you that
they're familiar with and rule number 50
the last time before a very special
bonus clip is manage your relationships
well over the years I've had to learn
how to disconnect myself from people how
to pull away how to move on without what
I call Benihana in people now I don't
know if you remember but if you ever go
to a Benihana restaurant they have those
sharp knives and they kind of go and you
don't even know that the zucchini is
like all diced up until they move it and
then everything is kind of part well I
used to have a habit of like cutting
people off so well so fast that
I felt like I've been haunted them like
they didn't know they were like all
slice and dice until they went to walk
away and their hand fell off and then
their arms fell off and I over the years
I had to learn how do I complete by the
way I would say don't break up with
people don't break away from people
don't stop being their friends a better
mindset is recognized when the
relationship is just complete now I say
completes a complete with me when I say
complete that means the relationship has
had every experience that it needs to
have you've done everything you need to
do and it's just complete so you don't
have to make people wrong
that was a big lesson for me because
we're taught that in order for
relationships to end someone's brains
need to be splattered on the ceiling
well the older wiser me recognizes that
I can end relationships from people who
I've outgrown our people who might be
toxic or people are just out of fit for
me and also leave their dignity intact
g-word I want you to write that down
type that in chat because there is a way
that you can complete with people notice
I'm using these key words with you you
can complete with people meaning every
experience that we need to have we've
had and now I'm complete that you can do
that and leave their dignity intact you
can say this relationship has run its
course you don't have to outline
everything that's not working because
you know when we outline things that are
not working all we're doing is making
people wrong so let me just say the way
you complete a relationship is to first
check your ego because your ego our
ladies your she go woo they will get in
the way and what you want to do is point
point point point point I'm done with
you because of this this and this and we
all know when you point one finger over
there the three fingers point back at
you we've all heard it now I've got a
special bonus gift from Lisa on how to
fail for that
enjoy but before that is some for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go question number one
what relationships do you need to manage
better question number two how can you
better own your brilliance and question
number three what baby-step can you take
towards your goals today you know so
often people are consumed with fear the
fear of judgment that's a huge one the
fear of failure what happens if it
doesn't work the fear of success what
happens if it does work and people see
me like they really see me for who I am
what happens if I get hurt in a
relationship like there's so many what
is but what happens when you what if
yourself all over yourself you never
think about the what if it works what if
what if it has just just as much chance
at working as it doesn't not working and
what if you redefine what we call
failure and in my language I love it in
the book abundance now that I wrote and
many of you have read it I talked about
you can fail all day long just fail
forward the only distinction between a
bunch of really successful individuals
and a bunch of individuals really
wanting success is that the successful
individuals we're willing to fail and
they did fail they just failed forward
some of my best lessons are born out of
my failures literally to this day and my
failures these days cost six figures or
more but I'm willing to do that because
I want the lesson or the outcome and if
you allow a failure to feed your futures
what I call feeding your future meaning
what are the two things that I did
really well and what's the one area that
I can improve upon or what's the three
things I did really well and what are
the two areas that I can improve upon
and then take those two things and pull
those that lesson forward or take the
three things that you did well and make
sure you don't lose those to me the
tragedy the tragedy of when something
doesn't go the way you thought is when
you only beat yourself up from it you
never ever
look at what did I do well and where can
I improve if you want Lisa Nichols top
five pieces of life-changing advice
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I'm an
average ordinary woman who chose every
day to make one more extraordinary
decision every single failure has a
lesson in it